elon musk is moving their headquarters
out of the san francisco bay area in
california to austin texas that's what's
going on
that's what happens when you say dumb
[ __ ] to rich people joe hit us with what
the uh pullback
pull up your tweet just read us the uh
the four things that happened joe's
joe's going viral right now viral yeah
go check it out on twitter joe's going
viral at the moment he uh currently has
a tweet that is uh just out there and if
you have kids watching this show close
your ears for for five five seconds kids
kids kids
don't use this language kids so lorena
gonzalez who is an assemblywoman in uh
california
tweeted out on may 9th 2020 and just
literally just said [ __ ] elon musk not
sure why not sure what caused that
whatever but she tweeted that out so
elon musk famously said uh message
received said okay i
hear you on that one heard
sounds good and then uh cnbc reported
along with a bunch of other people
yesterday on the earnings call he
finally this has been i think in the
works for a while but he said tesla's
moving its headquarters uh from
california to austin texas finally
admitted it
she
obviously doubled down
and decided to attempt to dunk on him
again genius yeah
which is obviously the right thing to do
for sure and she uh put a crying
laughing emoji and said you mean elon
musk is such a snowflake he moved from
california because i censored a bad word
about him wow isn't that weak
quite the response there the worst thing
you could do is double down that
situation i think
yeah that that is uh is probably not the
brightest thing to do especially
considering the move was done at that
point i guess uh but elon musk right
like there's a bunch of other things
that go into this it's a year after the
initial tweet it's obviously been in the
works for a long period of time it's not
just her tweet look he's he's not an
idiot he didn't just someone talk [ __ ]
to him on the internet it was like all
right i'm moving my entire business
right like a bunch of other things that
go into it but kovit had to do with it
they put a lot of uh you know
regulations and rules and simulations on
how he was able to run his business
there's obviously high taxes that are
lower in texas a bunch of workers all
this kind of there's a bunch of stuff
that goes into is my point but calling
out the world's richest person that has
a ton a ton a ton of jobs in your in
your state and is one of probably the
greatest innovators and one of the
greatest entrepreneurs of our lifetime
is a stupid stupid move just incredibly
idiotic and now she's doubling down
trying to dunk on him even further makes
no sense in my opinion and to be quite
frank like i think she deserves kind of
all of the responses that she's getting
uh for doing this she's a socialist
[Laughter]
that's what it is if you condemn success
you're a socialist if you want to
redistribute wealth you're a socialist
let's just call what it is somehow in
this country we're trying to normalize
this nonsense you're a socialist if you
literally think that this is a good
thing if you celebrate when a capitalist
moves away when a capitalist takes their
job economic impact away when they take
technology and innovation away and they
move them out of your jurisdiction and
you celebrate not only are you a [ __ ]
but you're a socialist that's what you
are so okay great let's see how this
plays out if we're gonna have
politicians in certain states be
socialists and other states are gonna be
capitalist i'm not a betting man but uh
i guess i bet you we can use history as
an example of what states are gonna do
better and what states aren't remember
there are so many people that left
california and new york over the last
year that they literally lost political
seats that's how many people left
hundreds of thousands of people fled
these states to go to other places where
they felt they had more freedom so again
if you want to sit there and you want to
go after these folks it's become cool to
bash success it's become cool to attack
them online they're just gonna move why
are they gonna stay there why are they
gonna continue to expose themselves to
your nonsense right so congratulations
yes you can sit get there twitter
retweets you can get all the twitter
likes you want you can yell and scream
with all of your friends and say look
what we made elon musk do you know what
elon musk is saying
guess what those idiots are going to
keep doing this and more and more and
more companies are going to continue to
leave san francisco is going through
what detroit went through years and
years ago
literally detroit was the heart of
capitalism it was the auto manufacturer
of the entire world
detroit went through some really tough
times san francisco's doing the exact
same thing they're making a lot of the
same exact policy mistakes
if you are abrasive to capitalism and
democracy and you continue to try to
condemn success those who create jobs
who create economic impact and who drive
innovation and job creation
they are going to leave
they have more flexibility to leave
today than ever before
and so if you keep doing nonsense
they're going to leave and that's
exactly what he did and it wouldn't
surprise me if at some point in the
future he moved spacex as well
it's going to be really hard at first to
do it because spacex has a ton of
infrastructure et cetera built down
there in l.a but tesla was in palo alto
we out
see ya we're out of here i i think when
you uh when you start to think about it
right like the combination of super high
taxes uh high crime in certain areas
certainly in san francisco and then
shaming entrepreneurs and shaming the
people that you want to build businesses
and bring jobs and your thing that's a
losing strategy right and we're seeing
it play out in real time literally he
took his entire business and said hey
the headquarters is moving to texas all
these new jobs we're going to create in
the future this company's going to
continue to grow continue to scale
continue to do all these things they're
all going to be in texas right so you're
losing out on not only uh kind of that
reputation that ability to attract other
people but you're losing out on tangible
things right like tax revenue and all
this other stuff so
look those are a bad combination there's
only so long that uh good weather can
hold out for and say hey look we're
gonna attract people based on these
things so big l uh for the assemblywoman
and uh i'd be surprised if this isn't
kind of like a gut check for a lot of
politicians within california if you are
a politician or representative that
represents me as an american citizen
please do not talk [ __ ] to entrepreneurs
and innovators that are trying to help
us
it's absolutely ridiculous don't want to
see it um
i wish elon and i wish this woman much
success in what they do but i don't need
politicians and representatives kind of
going back and forth with other people
on the internet that's not how you guys
should be communicating in ways what did
they do in like and when you were like
in elementary school and stuff they went
like this like loser yeah
she took an l she took it out
she took an l what what is what would
you do if you were uh the politician now
yeah no oh
well we've seen what she's done right so
she has doubled down and said more
ridiculous statements uh but now she's
quoting that elon said yeah we're going
to add 20 000 jobs or whatever over the
coming years but the whole point was the
headquarters moving right so all the
other stuff is is translating out to
texas and all the future growth is going
to be going there and all this stuff so
uh i think at this point like
you're you're doing damage control right
like she's not going to she's obviously
doubling down she had a very very very
strong opinion i think her original
tweet got like 180 000 likes so whether
she thinks it was the right or wrong
thing there was some kind of like social
uh backing there so i think that
probably uh made her double down on this
and do all that uh but i don't know i
think i think it's tough she obviously
shouldn't have done it in the first
place but i think you want to reverse
course immediately as possible and be
like that's not what we intended to do
we want people like this to stay in our
community stay in our uh economy attract
more people this is not what we want to
represent
and i don't know how the hierarchy
necessarily works kind of when it comes
to assemblywoman and their social
structure within the government uh
especially kind of related to california
and her expertise uh but if i'm higher
than her if i'm newsom and all this i'm
saying [ __ ] that you know what i mean
like let's figure this out like let's
let's get him back here and let's
attract other people because i think if
you uh start to see this this is one big
example but over time this stuff plays
out and it plays out really really bad
when it starts to come down on top of
each other would you apologize would you
explicitly say i'm sorry i messed up yes
john
i don't know speaks to austin though
the city
elon has a quote saying there's a limit
to how big you can scale in the bay area
in austin our factory is like five
minutes from the airport 15 minutes from
downtown so another win for the lone
star state